arabanızın lastiği patladığında
değiştirmek için kriko kullanmışsınızdır
burada izlediğiniz sistemdeki gibi bir
çubuğu elinizle ya da ayağınızla yukarı
aşağı hareket ettirdiğinizde arabayı
böyle küçük küçük yükselttiğinizi
görürsünüz koca arabayı 5 kişi tutup
kaldıramadığımız halde Elimizin ya da
ayağımızın ufak bir hareketiyle nasıl
böyle kaldırabiliyoruz bu sistem nasıl
çalışıyor veya berber koltuklarında 80
kilo 90 kilo adamlar oturuyorlar berber
ayağının ufacık bir hareketiyle hiç
zorlanmadan Siz böyle tık tık tık tık
yukarı kaldırıyor Normalde sizi
kucaklayıp kaldıramayacak olan adam
ufacık bir ayak hareketiyle bunu nasıl
yapıyor Bunların hepsi bizim bugün Su
cenderesi olarak işleyeceğimiz hidrolik
sistemlerle oluyor gençler temel prensip
önceki derslerimizde öğrendiğimiz Pascal
prensibi yani sıvılar üzerlerine
uygulanan basıncı her yöne Aynen
iletiyorlar bunu Gören fizikçiler de
bundan teknolojik alet oluşturuyorlar
günlük hayatta işe yarar bir şey
oluşturuyorlar daha küçük kuvvetlerle
daha büyük Kuvvetleri dengelemeyi
öğreniyorlar hatırlarsanız dengedeki
katılar üzerlerine uygulanan kuvveti
Aynen iletiyorlardı ama basıncı iletmek
zorunda değillerdi sıvılar ise kuvveti
değil ama basıncı Aynen iletebiliyorlar
işte Bu da bizim işimize çok yarıyor bu
sistemi bir inceleyelim su dolu bir
bileşik kap var şurada biraz daha dar
versiyon şurada biraz daha geniş
versiyon 2 tane rahatlıkla hareket
edebilen Şimdilik ağırlığını ihmal
edeceğim piston var X pistonu ve Y
pistonu buradaki y pistonu üzerine g
ağırlıklı bir yük koyuyorum Ve ben bunu
buradaki F kuvvetiyle dengeliyor önceki
derslerimizde öğrendik aynı sıvıda aynı
seviyede basınçlar eşittir şöyle bir
çizgi çeksem bu noktadaki basınçla Bu
noktadaki basıncın eşit olduğunu
biliyorum Hatta diyordum ki bunlar eşit
olmasa şu iki nokta arasında var
Olduğunu hayal ettiğim su kütlesi
hareket ederdi etmediğine göre sağdan
iten basınçla soldan iten basınç eşit
Bunlar birbirine denk geliyor
diyebiliriz Şimdi ben aynı seviyeyi daha
işe yarar bir yerden çeksem şuradan bir
yerden ka noktası var L noktası var
İkisi de aynı seviyedeler aynı sıvıyla
temas halindeler o zaman bunların
basınca eşittir Bu kırmızı noktada yani
K noktasındaki Basınç nedir yukarıdan
gelen kuvvet bir basınç oluşturuyor
şöyle bir alana etki ediyor x pistonunun
alanı ve basıncın genel ifadesi kuvvet
böyle alan olduğuna göre f/a x olabilir
bu kırmızı noktada bu basınç var bu
basınç bu sıvıya etki ediyor ve bu sıvı
bunu aynen buraya da aktarıyor buraya da
aktarıyor Şuraya da aktarıyor ve hatta
benim işime yarayacak şekilde bunu aynen
buraya da aktarıyor Peki neden yukarıya
çıkmıyor bu piston Çünkü üstünde de bir
yük var o da ağırlığından dolayı aşağıya
doğru bir basınç uyguluyor sistem
dengede olduğuna göre bu ikisi eşit O
yüzden K noktasının basıncı ile l'nin
basıncı eşittir L noktasındaki basınç
kuvvet bölü alan kuvvet dediğim şey
yükün ağırlığı g bölü buradaki y
pistonunun alanı kuvvetin etki ettiği
alan onu da a y olarak düşünelim İşte
bunlar eşitler bu denklemde Şu an bir
şey fark etmemiş olabilirsiniz ama biraz
daha derin düşündüğümüzde günlük
hayatımızı çok kolaylaştırabilecek bir
şey olduğunu görürüz çok abartılı
sayılar yazacağım mevzuyu daha iyi
anlayalım daha kolay anlayalım diye
Diyelim ki buraya böyle bir peynir
kalıbı koydum 100 gramlık bir peynir
kalıbı yer çekimi ile onunla çarparsam
bir newtona karşılık gelir abartılı
sayılar vereceğimi söylemiştim buradaki
piston alanına da 1 metrekare ediyorum
buradaki piston daha büyük buradaki
piston daha büyük olduğu için bir
metrekareden daha büyük bir şey
vereceğim diyelim ki 1000 metrekare ve
bu matematiğin sağlanması için burada
1/1'den 1 gelecek eşitliğin sağının da 1
olması için ağırlık dediğim şeyin 1000
Newton olması gerekiyor Bunu da kütle
cinsinden düşünürsem yani yer çekimine
bölersem 100 kilogram gibi bir şey
olacaktır Peki bu ne anlama geliyor 100
gramlık peynir kalıbıyla yani şu
arkadaşlar 100 kilogramlık bir yükü
Mesela bir insanı taşıyabilirsin
anlamına geliyor Arada 1000 kat fark var
işte Az önce izlediğimiz videolarda tam
olarak bununla çalışıyor küçük
kuvvetlerle daha büyük Kuvvetleri
dengeliyoruz elimin küçücük bir
hareketiyle kocaman arabayı
kaldırabiliyor hiç zorlanmıyorum sebebi
Az önce anlattığım mantık berber
Normalde kaldıramayacağı müşteriyi
ayağının ufacık bir hareketiyle çok
rahat bir şekilde gördüğünüz gibi ufak
ufak yükseltiyor veya bir iş makinesi
operatörü oturduğu yerde ufacık kollarla
oynayarak İşte bu sistem sayesinde koca
koca kayaları kaldırabiliyor ufak
kuvvetlerle büyük Kuvvetleri kontrol
ediyorsanız bir yerlerde oralarda
kesinlikle günümüzde hidrolik sistem
olarak adlandırılan bizim Az önce Su
cenderesi olarak gördüğümüz sistemler
vardır o sıvı dediğimiz şuralardaki
boruların içerisinde hareket ediyorlar
hidrolik sıvısı olarak isimlendiriyoruz
o Üzerine uygulanan basıncı her yöne
Aynen iletiyor basınçlar eşit olacağı
için küçük alana uyguladığın kuvvet daha
büyük bir alana denk geldiğinde basınç
aynı basınç alan büyüdü o zaman kuvvetin
de büyümesi gerekiyor Böylece daha büyük
kuvveti dengelemiş oluyoruz işte kriko
ile araba kaldırmanın hidrolik bir
sistemle araba yükseltmenin mantığı
tamamen bu simülasyonda var buradan
kolla Biz aşağıya doğru hareketimizi
yapıyoruz Şuradaki pistona bir kuvvet
uyguluyoruz sıvıyı buradan itiyoruz bu
basıncı sıvı Aynen buraya kadar
aktarıyor ve böylece arabayı yükseltmiş
oluyoruz Normalde Benim anlattığım
sistemde bir kere itebilirsin sonra geri
aldığında sıvı geri gelir Ama burada
sürekli yeni bir sıvı iletebiliyorum
Nereden geliyor bu sıvının kaynağı
aslında gerçekte şurada bir depo var bu
Depodaki su Sen yukarıya sıvı
pompaladıkça tekrar senin pistonunun
altına geliyor baştan başlatayım bakın
Biz buradan suyu itiyoruz bu Depodan
yeni su geliyor onu tekrar itiyoruz
Depodan yeni su geliyor onu tekrar
itiyoruz Biz burada küçücük bir alan
üzerine kuvvet uyguluyoruz burada bir p
yardımcı oluşturuyoruz aynı p basıncı
burada kocaman bir alan üzerinde etkili
olduğu için basınç eşittir kuvvet böyle
alan basınç aynı kalacak alan arttığı
için kuvvetin de artması gerekiyor daha
büyük arabaları taşıyabiliyor Biz
itiyoruz su geliyor Biz itiyoruz su
geliyor diyelim ki burada durdurduk
araba artık aşağı insin istiyoruz ne
yaparız Şuradaki vanayı açarsak buradaki
su tekrar aşağıya dökülür ve araba
burada aşağıya iner her şey başa Sarar
diyebiliriz Peki bu araba krikolarında
ya da berber koltuklarında neden
cisimler ayağımızla bastığımız kadar
yükselmez yani biz itiyoruz 10
santimetre diyoruz ama o küçük küçük
yükseliyor tekrar simülasyona dönersek
bakın buradaki pistonun ilerleme miktarı
ile buradaki arabanın yükselme miktarı
arasında fark var bu çok fazla itiliyor
ama araba az az yükseliyor veya buradaki
çubuğun katettiği mesafeye dikkat edin
yukarı aşağı arabanın yükselme miktarına
bakın Çubuk çok fazla hareket ediyor ama
araba böyle bir santim bir santim
yükseliyor gibi çok az yükseliyor bir
yerden kazanıyorsak bir yerden
kaybetmemiz lazım Bunu zaten ayt'de
basit makinelerde görüyorsunuz şu an
işlediğimiz şeyde teorik olarak bir
basit makine aslında kuvvetten
kazanıyorsam yoldan kaybetmeliyim
ittiğimden daha az hareket
ettirebilmeliyim mantığı çok basit AYT
bilmeye gerek yok sıvıları
sıkıştıramadığımızı kabul ediyoruz
diyelim ki ben bu pistonla bu arkadaşı H
kadar itmiş olayım buradaki alanım a
kadar olsun buradaki alanımda 1000 a
kadar olsun 1000 kat daha büyük bir alan
olsun ve basınçların eşitliğinden
buradaki kuvvet F kadarsa buradaki yüküm
1000 F kadardır f/a basınç bir f/ 1000 a
basınç aynı basınç Yani ben F kadarlık
kuvvetimle 1000 f'lik 1000 kat daha
büyük bir kuvveti dengeleyebiliyorum
Şimdi ben buradaki suyu ittim şu
kadarlık suyu ittim bu hacimde suyu
ittim hacim taban alanı çarpı yükseklik
taban alana a kadar yükseklik haçka
kadar suyu sıkıştıramadığıma göre bu su
ne yapacak Tabii ki bu pistonu yukarıya
yetecek buradaki su seviyesi yukarıya
çıkacak mesela şuraya geldi burada ağaç
çarpı H kadarlık sıvı yükselmesi olmak
zorunda Çünkü bu kadar ittim
sıkıştıramadıysam O kadar yükselmeli
şimdi bizim burada alan dediğimiz şey
bina değil miydi Evet burası bina
alanına sahip o zaman buradaki yükselme
miktarı h/ kadar olmalı ki bu ifade ile
bu ifadeyi çarptığımda şunu bulmuş
olalım Yani ben H kadar itersem benim
yüküm onun binde biri kadar yükselir
h/1000 kadar yükselir kuvvetten 1000 kat
kazandım yoldan da bin kat kaybediyorum
adamı 1 metre itiyorum yükselsin diye
0.1 santim yükseliyor gibi
düşünebilirsiniz o yüzden bastığımız
kadar yükselmeyecektir bir başka günlük
hayat örneği de araba frenleri Normalde
50 ile 60'la yani çok hızlı da gitmeyen
bir arabanın karşısına geçseniz
Ellerinize tutmaya çalışsanız
tutamazsınız size Ezel geçer bütün
vücudunuza karşı koymanıza rağmen ama
ayağınızın ufacık bir hareketiyle
kocaman arabayı yavaşlatıp
durdurabiliyorsunuz hem de 50 60'la
gitmesine gerek yok 150-200 de gitse de
bunu yapabilirsiniz çok büyük kuvvetle
basmam gerekiyor gibi bir şey yok normal
basıyorsun Araba duruyor Çünkü burada da
hidrolik sistem var burada da Pascal
prensibi geçerli Burada da benzer bir
bileşik kap var sanayiyle haşır neşir
olanlar bilirler bakıma gidersiniz sizin
arabanızın bütün hidrolik sıvılarını
değiştirirler frendeki hidroliği
değiştirirler mesela bakım zamanı
geldiğinde bunu yapabilirler Neden Çünkü
sen hidrolik sıvısı kullanıyorsun çünkü
prensibi kullanıyoruz Bu normal su değil
özel bir sıvı Ayağında fren pedalını
ittiğinde Aslında Şuradaki pistona bir
kuvvet uygulamış oluyorsun Burada bir
basınç oluşturmuş oluyorsun bu basınç
Aynen buradaki tekerlekteki kampana
dediğimiz tekerleğe yapışan sistemleri
aktarılıyor aynı basınç bu pistonu bu
tarafa itiyor diğer pistonu da bu tarafa
itiyor Böylece tekerleği değiyor bu
kampanalar bisikletin tekerleğindeki o
kauçuklar gibi ve tekerleği yavaşlatmış
oluyorlar buradaki alan kuvvet
oranlarına göre de senin uyguladığın
kuvvet az olurken burada çok daha fazla
kuvvet elde etmiş oluyoruz filmlerde
fren patlama sahnelerini hatırlarsınız
Arabanın altından böyle bir sıvı Akar
İşte o sıvı buradaki hidrolik sıvısıdır
şu boru bir yerden delinir buradaki sıvı
böyle akar gider ortada sıvı olmazsa sen
basıncı kime uygulayacaksın da o
iletecek sıvı olması şart buna fren
patlamış diyoruz boşa çalışıyor Bu pedal
boşta kalmış oluyor basıyorsun hiçbir
etkisi olmamış oluyor çünkü basıncı
aktaracak bir sıvın olmuyor Şimdi
gelelim basınç kuvvetine katılarda da
bunu konuşmuştuk basınç dediğimiz şey
kuvvet böyle alan buradaki kuvvet
basıncın oluşmasına sebep olan basınç
kuvveti ben bu arkadaşı yalnız
bırakırsam o zaman basın çarpı alan
basınç kuvvetini verecektir su dolu sıvı
dolu bir kabımız var bunun tabanındaki
yüzeye etki eden bir kuvvet var Buna
basınç kuvveti diyoruz direkt şu an
kuvvetten bahsediyorum basınçtan
bahsetmiyorum Örneğin bu kapak patlayıp
aşağıya doğru çökebilir Bunun sebebi
basınç değildir Bunun sebebi basınç
kuvvetidir Çünkü cisimleri hareket
ettiren cisimleri hızlandıran cisimleri
yavaşlatan cisimlerin şeklini değiştiren
cisimleri kıran cisimleri parçalayan
şeyler kuvvettir basınç kuvvetin özel
bir tanımı basınç birim yüzey alanındaki
kuvvet demek yani şu tabanda komple her
yerde bir basınç kuvveti var basınç
dediğim şey tek bir noktadaki basınç
kuvveti Aslında bu noktalardan bir sürü
var bu tabanın alanı kadar var yani a
kadar var Ben buradaki bütün noktaları
hoplarsam Aslında p çarpı a yapmış olur
tek bir noktadaki şey basınç bütün
noktaların toplamı basınç kuvveti olarak
düşünülebilir p çarpı a tek bir
noktadaki basınç ne derinlikle
düşünülmeli sıvının seviyesini şöyle
düşünürsem haç derinliğ burada sıvı
varmış gibi hayal ediyorum o zaman tek
bir noktada benim HD kadar sıvı basıncım
var başka bir noktayı incelesem orada da
HD var başka bir nokta incelesem Orada
da hdg var işte bütün noktaların bütün
HD g'lerin toplamı bütün alan boyunca
toplamı hdg çarpı a demektir İşte biz
buna basınç kuvveti diyoruz tek bir
noktaya etki eden kuvvetten
bahsetmiyorum bütün yüzeye etki eden
kuvvetten bahsediyorum O yüzden genelde
kitaplarda böyle tek bir okla
gösterirler kuvveti sanki sadece
Şuradaki bir noktaya etki ediyormuş gibi
Hayır buradaki bütün yüzeye etki eden
bir şeyden bahsediyoruz uçak ve
denizaltı gibi araçların pencereleri
neden küçük hemen günlük hayatla
bağdaştıralım bunu Örneğin buradaki
şekle bakıyorum kocaman uçak var
yolcuların dışarıyı gördüğü pencereler
uçakta Küçücük yer kaplıyorlar Hadi
geçtim Yolcuları Kokpit kısmında
pilotların olduğu yerde adamlar önünü
görsün ki uçağa uçursun yine küçücük
pencereler var bunun özel bir sebebi
olabilir mi veya denizaltılarda
denizaltılarda hiç pencere yok Genelde
bazı Rus denizaltılarında ufacık
pencereler var Güzel olmaz mıydı böyle
küçük küçük pencereleri olsaydı denizin
izleseydik veya İstanbul'da Avrasya
Tüneli diye bir şey var arabalar
geçiyorlar denizin altından geçiyorlar
şöyle camekanlı olsaydı Ferah Ferah Her
yeri görseydik denizin altında fena
olmaz mıydı olurdu tabii bir sürü
sakıncası var ama bizim konumuzla ilgili
olana bakacağım ben sadece Yoksa tek
sebep şimdi anlatacağım şey değil tabii
ki bakın gençler basınç kuvveti
dediğimiz şey basınçla alanın
çarpılmasıyla bulunuyor denizaltı
dediğiniz şey denizin bayağı bayağı
altına iniyor Dolayısıyla üzerindeki
sıvı basıncı hdg'den düşünüldüğünde
buradaki ağaç o kadar inanılmaz sayılara
çıkıyor ki devasa bir basınca maruz
kalıyor dolayısıyla bir denizaltının
üzerinde çok fazla basınç etkisi var Bu
basıncın olduğu alanda çok büyük olursa
kuvvet devasa boyutlara çıkıyor bu da
denizaltı için büyük problem pencere
gibi şeyler normal bir denizaltının
diğer kısımlarına göre daha zayıf yine
bizim camımız kadar dayanıksız değiller
özel malzemelerle üretilebilirler ama
yine de riske atmaya değecek şeyler
değil ya hiç pencere koymuyorlar ya da
koyarlarsa çok çok küçük koyuyorlar yani
bari şu Ağayı çok küçük tutalım yani p
zaten büyük bari şu a'yı küçük tutalım
ki Neticede maruz kalacağımız kuvvet
nispeten daha küçük kalsın Uçaklarda da
aynı şey geçerli ama uçakta tam tersi
var uçak yukarılara çıktıkça etrafındaki
açık hava basıncı azalıyor yolcuların
bulunduğu yerde yüksek basınç var
dışarıda Alçak basınç var Dolayısıyla
içeriden dışarıya doğru bir basınç
kuvveti var bir zorlama var yüksek
basınçtan alçak basınca doğru akmaya
çalışıyor içerideki hava Aslında
uçakların camları içeriden zorlanıyor
yani o pencereleri küçük yapalım ki daha
az kuvvete maruz kalalım hiçbir
denizaltının içini gördüğünüz mü ya da
bir belgesel izlediniz mi bilmiyorum ama
çok küçük koridorları o kadar dar ki iki
kişi yan yana geçemiyorlar o kadar
ufacık yerlerde yatıyorlar ki ayağa
kalksalar kafalarını tavana çarpıyorlar
niye bu kadar küçük tasarlanıyor Bunlar
Çünkü yüzey alanını küçültmek istiyorlar
Yani iş sadece pencerede de bitmiyor
denizaltı olabileceği minimum hacimde
tasarlanıyor ki minimum yüzey alanına
sahip olsun alan küçük olursa basınç
kuvveti de daha küçük olur Çünkü denizin
altına indikçe inanılmaz basınçlara
maruz kalıyorsunuz Örneğin geçen aylarda
ortamlara haber düştü Titanic enkazına
dalmaya çalışan Ocean Gate diye bir
firmanın ufacık denizal diyemeyeceğimiz
bir aracıyla okyanusun dibine dalmaya
çalıştılar araç küçücükte içinde 5 kişi
vardı o 5 kişi böyle Resmen yan yana
oturuyordu Neden Çünkü yüzey alanı ne
kadar küçük olursa o kadar az basınca
maruz kalırsın adamlar yaklaşık üç buçuk
kilometre aşağıya indiler Titanic
battına ulaşmak için hala inmeleri
gerekiyordu ama yolda başlarına maalesef
kötü bir olay geldi Çünkü o araçları
yeteri kadar teste kontrole tabi
tutulmamıştı gençler 3 buçuk kilometre
Deniz derinliği demek santimetre kare
başına yaklaşık 350 kg düşüyor demek
yani parmağınızın ucu kadarlık bir alana
bir motosiklet falan koyduğunuzu düşünün
böyle bir şeyden bahsediyoruz ufacık bir
hassas bir zayıf nokta olduğunda oradan
içe patlama dediğimiz olayı yaşıyorsunuz
Bu da bir patlama ama içe doğru patlama
basınç kuvveti basınçla çok ilgili
olduğu gibi alanla da çok ilgiyle Peki
şimdi biz tabandaki basınç kuvvetini
hesapladık ama basıncın yan yüzeylerde
de olduğunu biliyoruz yan yüzeylerde
basınç varsa o zaman orada da basınç
kuvveti vardır Onu nasıl hesaplayacağız
hocam aynı şey işte kuvvet dediğimiz şey
o yüzeydeki bir noktadaki basınç çarpı o
yüzeyin tamamını alanı bunları oradaki
kuvveti buluyoruz İyi de şöyle bir
problem var basınç yerine ne yazacaksın
hangi noktayı alacaksın yani şu noktayı
alırsan farklı bir derinlik var bu
noktaya alırsam farklı bir derinlik var
Şu noktayı alırsam farklı bir derinlik
var Hangi basınç tabanı aldığımızda çok
kolaydı tabanda hangi noktaya bakarsan
bak ister buraya bak derinlik aynı
buraya bak derinlik aynı buraya bak
derinlik aynı basınç hep sabitti orada
bir problem yaşamıyorduk ama yan
yüzeylerde basınç aşağıya doğru indikçe
artıyor Bu işin içinden nasıl çıkacağız
çok basit bizim basınç dediğimiz şey HD
en üst noktada sıvının en üst yüzeyinde
sıvı basıncı yok sıfır en alt noktada 4h
yükseklik tanımlanmış 4 taş derinlik
tanımlanmış o zaman 4 HD basınç var
aşağıya doğru indikçe düzgün artıyor O
zaman ben bunun ortalamasını alabilirim
en üstteki basınç sıfır en alttaki
basınç 4A DG bu şekil için ben basınç
yerine 0 +
4hg/2 yazabilir ortalamasını aldık çarpı
İşte bu yan yüzeyin alanı yan yüzeyimiz
A1 kadarmış çarpı A1 diyebiliriz
buradaki işlemi yaptığım zaman ne oluyor
iki HD
sanki bakın Altını çiziyorum sanki orta
noktaya göre alıyormuşuz gibi
düşüneceğiz orta noktadaki basıncı
hesaplamamız gerekiyormuş gibi
düşüneceğiz Dolayısıyla yan bir yüzey
gördüğümde orta noktasından Bakıyorum bu
şekilde İki aşk var iki ağaç derinlik
üzerinden diyeceğim ki iki ağaç DG çarpı
yüzeyin tamamı yani A1 kadarlık bir
basınç kuvveti vardır Bütün bu yüzeyde
diyeceğiz Niye sanki diye özellikle
belirtiyorum Çünkü buradaki basınç
kuvvetlerinin ortalaması tam ortası
çıkmaz daha aşağıya yakın çıkar Çünkü
aşağıdaki basınç Kuvvetleri sayıca büyük
Yukarıdaki basınç Kuvvetleri sayıca
küçük bu ikisinin bileşkesi alındığını
aşağıda bir yerde çıkar kuvvetin
uygulanma yeri ama ben onunla
ilgilenmiyorum ben bu yüzeydeki toplam
basınç kuvvetine bakmak istiyorum o
yüzden basıncın ortalaması çarpı toplam
alan diyorum ve basıncın ortalaması orta
noktadan almak gibi bir şey olduğu için
de Herhangi bir problem çıkmıyor mesela
şu yüzeye etki eden F2 ile tarif edilen
basınç kuvveti nedir Eğer sadece buraya
odaklanacaksam yine yan yüzey nereden
alacağım ben basıncı ortadan alacakmışım
gibi düşüneceğim tamamını iki ağaç demiş
ortanın derinliği haş kadar o zaman F2
dediğim şey Flash DG çarpı buradaki
yüzeyin alanıdır yani a2'dir diyebiliriz
F3 için ne yapacağım şöyle çapraz bir
yüzey çapraz olunca başka bir şey mi var
Hayır aynı şey bu yüzeyin en üstüne ve
en altına bakıyorum En üstündeki basınç
nedir derinlik nedir iki ağaç derinlikte
burada 2hg var En altta ne var 4h En
altta 4h DG var aşağıya doğru indikçe bu
basınç düzgün artıyor 2'den 4'e o zaman
bunların ortalaması nedir 3 ay dg'dir
çarpı alan ne kadar alan A3 kadar o
zaman F3 dediğim şeyin değeri bu
kadardır yine Aslında ne yaptım sanki 3h
derinlikteki basınçtan hesaplamışım gibi
oldu yani orta noktadan hesaplamışım
gibi oldu ve Burası H Burası 2h toplam
derinlik 3 ay diyebiliriz yan yüzey
varsa ortalama basınca al yüzeyle çarpıp
bir Mimar olsaydınız hidroelektrik
santrallerin yani barajların suyu tutan
duvarını nasıl tasarlardınız bunu önceki
derslerde konuşmuştuk zaten Tekrar uzun
uzun anlatmaya gerek yok baraj duvarları
aşağıya doğru indikçe kalınlaşan
duvarlardır suyunda şöyle Olduğunu hayal
edersek burada olduğunu Hayal edersek
aşağıya doğru
şurada sol tarafa doğru basınç kuvveti
etki ediyor sıvı yüzünden bu pistona sağ
tarafa doğru bir basınç kuvveti etki
ediyor Sıvının basıncı yüzünden bu
basınç Kuvvetleri nasıl yazılıyor basınç
çarpı o yüzeyin alanıyla bulunuyor
Bunlar Şimdi bunlar yan yüzey az önce
konuştuk yan yüzeyse basıncı yazarken
nereden alacağım ve orta noktadan
alacağım Şu noktayı düşünürsem ne kadar
derinlikte iki haç derinlikte O zaman
burada basıncımız iki hdg olarak
düşünülebilir ortalama buradaki alanda
iki Haçlı orantılı ki zaten 2A alana
sahip demiş ben oraya direkt 2A diyorum
4h DG a katsayı 4 olduğu için buradaki
basınç kuvvetine 4F diyorum yani bu
piston sıvı tarafından sola doğru 4 fle
itiliyor diye düşünüyorum e gitmiyor
çünkü onu fa tutuyor O zaman efka ne
kadar olmalı 4F kadar olmalı geldim
alttaki pistona alttaki piston yine bir
yan yüze sıvı onu sağ tarafa doğru
zorluyor Peki ne kadarlık bir kuvvetle
zorluyor yine orta noktasından hesap
yaparsam ne kadar derinlikte Burası 1 2
3 4 4 HD basınç var burada alan ne kadar
a kadar sonra 4h DG çarpı a o zaman bu
da 4F demek yani su bu pistonu sağ
tarafa doğru 4fre zorluyor gidiyor mu
gitmiyor o zaman fp de 4F kadar yani
Sorumun cevabı 1 ama bu daha derindeydi
daha çok suyu tutuyordu yukarıdan daha
çok basınca maruz kalıyordu Evet daha
çok basınca maruz kaldı 4hg Yukarıdaki
iki aç DG idi ama basınç kuvveti sadece
basınçla ilgili değil basınç çarpı alan
da önemli Evet uçağın dışında az Basınç
var ama pencereyi küçük yaparsan biraz
olsun işleri kolaylaştırmış olurum alanı
küçük tutmalıyım Yukarıdaki alan iki a
aşağıdaki alan bir a Yani bu arkadaş az
basıncı tutuyor ama çok cephede
savaşıyor 4 F Bu adam çok basıncı
tutuyor ama daha az cephede savaşıyor O
da 4'ü yüzeyinde önemli olduğunu
unutmamalıyız düşey kesti verilen de
özkütleli sıvıyla doldurulmuş şekildeki
kabın taban ve eğimli yüzeyleri a kadar
alana sahipmiş Buna göre bu alanları
etki eden sıvı basınç kuvvetlerinin
oranının bulunuz demiş iki tane alanı
inceleyeceğim İkisi de a kadar eğimli
olan ve taban basınç kuvveti p çarpı E
zaten İkisinde de alan aynı olduğu için
bakmama bile gerek yok basınçları
hesaplasam bana yeter Burası taban hangi
noktadan bakarsan bakayım aynı basınç
var mı Evet ne kadar derinlik 5h O zaman
burada 5h DG var E bunu alanla çarparsam
o zaman bütün bu yüzeydeki basınç
kuvveti ne kadarmış 5 f'miş diyebilirim
şimdi geldim yan yüzeye ortasından
alacağım ya da En üstün ve en altın
ortalamasını alacağım en üstte ne var
3hg var En altta ne var 5h DG var
bunların ortalaması 4A dg'dir basıncı 4h
DG aldım alan a kadar o zaman bu da
4ftir yani bu yüzeye etki eden komple
basınç kuvveti 4F kadarmış oranlayın
diyor cevabımız 5/4'tür şimdi geçen
dersimizde bir soru tipi çözmüştük buna
çok benziyordu orada buralara girmemek
için kendimi çok zor tuttum daha fazla
kafanızı karıştırmak istemedim açıkçası
ama burada artık bir açıklama getirelim
çok mantıklı bir soru soruyorum burada
diyorum ki sıvılarda ağırlıklarından
dolayı basınç uyguluyorlarsa katılardaki
gibi basınç Kuvvetleri ağırlıklarına
eşit midir o soruyu da zaten
hatırlayacaksınız bakın burada diyelim
ki g ağırlıklı bir Sıvı al şu
menteşelerden bu yan duvarları oynuyor
ben bunu açtım hafif kenarlara çekersem
suyun seviyesi azalacaktır aynı g sıvısı
ağırlık aynı sıvı aynı Çünkü haçtan daha
küçük bir derinliğe sahip olacaktır
mesela
0.5h diye Sallayalım bunu Bu yan
duvarları daraltırsam o zaman sıvıyı
yükseltmiş olurum o soruda biraz daha
çizimle göstermiştim şu an anlamakta
zorlanan varsa Orayı tekrar
izleyebilirler daha yükseğe çıkar Burası
hars ise sallıyorum tamamen iki Haşa
çıkar şimdi bu sıvıların tabandaki
basınçlarını yazsam 1 sıvıda Hah işte g
yazarım ikinci sıvıda 0.5 derinlik
olduğu için 0.5 HD g yazarım 3 sıvıda
iki ağaç derinlik olduğu için iki haçta
g yazar Yani basınçlar aynı değil Burada
basınç çok bu ortanca Bu da en küçük
basınç O soru da demiştim ki basınçları
kıyaslayınız Aynı burada yaptığım gibi
yazmıştık sonra B şıkkında demiştim ki
bu kapların yere uyguladığı basınçları
bulunuz şimdi kapların bu zemine
uyguladığı basınç diyorsan artık katı
basıncı düşünmelisin katı basıncını da
şuradan düşünebilirim yani kuvvet böyle
alandan düşünebilirim kapların ağır
ihmal yalnız Gerçi ihmal etmesem de olur
çünkü aynı kaplar sadece daralttım veya
genişlettim yan yüzeylerle oynadım ama
kafamız karışmasın ihmal edelim ve
ağırlık dediğim şey zaten sıvı olmayacak
mı o zaman yani birinci kapta ne
yazacağım g yazacağım alan a kadar
ikinci kapta yine aynı g var alan a
kadar 3 kapta yine aynı sıvı Burada da g
sıvısı var Bu da a kadar yani bu
kapların yere uyguladıkları basınçlar
eşit çıkıyor ve katıların basıncının
sebebi ağırlıklar ve sıvıların
basıncının sebebi de ağırlıklar Niye o
zaman katı basıncı olarak düşündüğümde
zemine yaptığım basınçlar eşit çıkarken
sıvı basıncı olarak düşündüğümde kabın
tabanındaki basınçlar eşit çıkmıyorlar
çok mantıklı soru Çünkü gençler bunları
katı olarak düşündüğümde dışarıdan
sadece kap olarak düşündüğümde Bunlar
kendi halinde takılıyorlar bunlara dış
müdahale yok ama sıvı olarak
düşündüğümde bunlara dış müdahale var ne
demek istiyorum birinci şekilde sıkıntı
yok kabımız düzgün bir şekil ama ikinci
şeklimizde sıvı bu kabın yan
yüzeyleriyle temas ettiği için temas
kuvveti oluşuyor fizikte iki cisim temas
ederse orada temas kuvveti olur yüzeye
dik olan normal kuvvet oluşur Bu yüzeyin
eğikliğinden dolayı yüzeye dik şöyle bir
normal kuvvet oluşur Burada da böyle bir
normal kuvvet oluşur 3 şekilde de yüzeye
dik böyle bir normal kuvvet yüzey dik
böyle bir normal kuvvet oluşur Bakın bu
kuvvetler sıvıya etki ediyor ve böyle
çapraz yukarıya doğru etki ediyorlar
sıvıyı havaya kaldırıyormuş gibi o
yüzden bu sıvının ağırlığının tamamı
Tabana aktarılmıyor tabandaki basınç
kuvvetine FF dersem tabandaki sıvı
basınç kuvveti sıvının kendi
ağırlığından daha küçüktür çünkü bütün
ağırlık aktarılamaz Bu normal kuvvetler
havaya kaldırıyormuş gibi olur aynı
şekilde buradaki normal kuvvetler
yukarıdan çapraz aşağıya bastırıyormuş
gibi sıvının kendi ağırlığından çok daha
fazlasını sıvı basınç kuvveti olarak
Tabana aktarır tabandaki sıvı basınç
kuvveti cismin ağırlığından daha
büyüktür Burada ise yan yüzeyler tamamen
yatayda çıkacağı için ağırlığa herhangi
bir katkıları olmayacak bunlar zaten
Birbirini götürür Dolayısıyla
tabağındaki basınç kuvveti direkt
sıvının ağırlığını ta kendisidir aynı
katılar gibi şimdi ben size 3 tane katı
çiziyorum şurası zeminimiz birinci
katımız Bu ikinci katımız bu 3 katımız
da bu g ağırlığı var g ağırlığı var g
ağırlığı var bakın bunların üçü de katı
sıvı falan yok katılarda tabandaki
basınç kuvveti nedir ağırlığın ta
kendisidir buradaki basınç kuvveti
tabanda ağırlıktır Burada da ağırlıktır
burada da ağırlıktır şekilden tamamen
bağımsız O yüzden ben 3 şekilde de
kapların basıncı hesaplarken basınç
kuvvetlerine g yazdım üçünde de Çünkü
basınç kuvveti katılarda ağırlığa eşit
sıvılarda Niye öyle olmuyor niye daha
büyük ya da daha küçük çıkabiliyor çünkü
mesela Şuradaki katıya şöyle bir kuvvet
uygulasam Bir de böyle bir kuvvet
uygulasam bak aynı Bu arkadaşlar gibi
yani bu katıyı böyle kenarlarından
tuttum hafif kaldırmaya çalışıyorum
yerle teması da kesilmiyor bu ağırlığın
tamamı aktarılabilir mi kaldırdın değil
mi zemini o kadar da basamaz artık ne
yazarsın zemine basan basınç kuvveti
ağırlıktan daha küçük olur dersin ben de
sıvıyı aynı şeyi yazdım zaten veya ben
bu adama şöyle kuvvetler çizsem soldan
ve sağdan böyle kenarlardan bastırıyorum
aynı Bunlar gibi daha çok bastırıyorum O
zaman o zemine daha çok basmaz mı Evet
kendi daha fazlası etki etmez mi
buradaki zemine Evet tabandaki basınç
kuvveti cismin ağırlığından Büyük Olur
mu evet E ben de öyle yazdım ikinci ve
üçüncü şekilde sıvılara dışarıdan
müdahale var Dışarıdan müdahale olduğu
için tabandaki basınç kuvveti
ağırlıklarına eşit olmuyor ama müdahale
olmadığında aynı katılar gibi düzgün bir
kabın içerisindeki sıvının ağırlığı
tabandaki basınç kuvvetine eşittir şöyle
bir kapta yanlar kaldırıyormuş gibi
olduğu için Tabana daha az kuvvet
aktarırsın ağırlıktan küçük bir kuvvet
aktarırsın böyle bir kapta kenarlardan
bastırıyormuş gibi olduğu için tabanda
ağırlıktan daha büyük bir kuvvet olur Bu
katılarla yaptığım işlemi eşleştirmeyi
zihninizde ihmal etmeyin Şuradaki
mevzuyu kavradığınızda burada ne demek
istediğimi anlayacaksınız hemen bunun Bu
soruda uygulamasında yapalım ve
dersimizi bitirelim düşerek kesti
şekildeki gibi olan kabın içi bir miktar
sıvıyla doludur bu durumdayken sıvının
ağırlığı GAP tabanına uyguladığı basınç
kuvveti F kadarmış hemen yazıyorum bakın
burada sıvımız var bu sıvımızın g'ye
kadarlık ağırlığı var kap tabanındaki
basınç kuvveti bu F dediğim şey sıvının
Tabana uyguladığı basınç kuvveti Hocam
işte basınç kuvveti yorumlayacağız nasıl
yapıyorduk bas çarpı alan yapıyorduk
işte yükseklik falan vermesi gerekmiyor
mu işte vermemiş O yüzden ben başka
şeylerle yorumlamaya çalışıyorum
ağırlıkla kıyaslıyorum ki zaten bana onu
soruyor formül sormuyor bana bununla
işim yok şu an basınç kuvveti dendiğinde
her seferinde bu formülü yazmak zorunda
değil Şu durumda ağırlıkla kuvvet
arasında nasıl bir ilişki var sıvının
bütün ağırlığı var mıdır bu kabın
tabanında Hayır daha fazlası vardır
sıvının tabanına sıvının kendi
ağırlığından daha fazlası aktarılır
Çünkü bu yan yüzeyler şekilleri yüzünden
şurası 90 derece olmak zorunda temas
kuvveti normal kuvvet uyguluyorlar
kenarlardan bastırıyorlar kenarlardan
bastırdıkları için tabanda ağırlıktan
daha büyük bir kuvvet oluşuyor bunu
şöyle Hayal edebilirsiniz düzgün bir
kabınız var içinde su var tabanı da
böyle çürük patladı patlayacak Ama şu an
patlamış durumda değil Siz bunu
kenarlardan böyle sıkıştırmaya
başlarsanız o taban patlayabilir Çünkü
kap düzgünken tabandaki basınç kuvveti
ağırlığa eşittir Ama sen kenarlardan
böyle daraltırsan şu Kuvvetleri
oluşturmuş olursun bu kuvvet ağırlıktan
daha büyük hale gelip o tabanı
patlatabilir kap ters çevrilirse bu
ağırlık tabandaki basınç kuvveti nasıl
değişir kamu şöyle yapacağız burada
geniş zemin oturmuştuk burada dar zemin
oturduğumuz için sıvı seviyesi bir kere
daha yukarıya çıkacak Ama fark etmez
sıvı aynı sıvı aynı g var tabandaki
basınç kuvvetimiz bu sefer F üssü olsun
G ile F üssü arasındaki ilişki nedir bu
kabın kenarları yüzeye dik bir şekilde
şöyle normal kuvvetler uygulayacak
kaldırıyormuş gibi olacak o yüzden bu
ağırlığın tamamı aktarılmayacak daha az
aktarılacak o yüzden tabandaki basınç
kuvveti bu sıvının ağırlığından daha
küçük olacak yani elinizdeki şişenin
tabanı patlamasın istiyorsanız
sıkıştırmak değil daha da böyle
genişletmek lazım Bu yan yüzeylerin de
sıvıyı kaldırmaya yardımcı olması lazım
ki Tabana daha az yük binsin kabı ters
çevirdiğimde sıvının ağırlığı Tabii ki
değişmez sıvı aynı sıvı ama tabandaki
basınç kuvveti azalır diyebiliriz Burada
ağırlıktan daha büyüklük burada
ağırlıktan daha küçüğüz kap ters
çevrildiğinde kabın zemine uyguladığı
basınç ve basınç kuvveti nasıl değişir
Bak az önce vurguladığımız şey kabın
diyor yani katı bir şeyden bahsediyor
içindeki sıvıyı unut içinde ne olduğu
beni ilgilendirmez Dışarıdan bakıyorum
böyle katı bir kap ağırlığı sadece
içindeki sıvı oluşturuyor düşünürsem
basınç dediğim şey kuvvet böyle alan
buradaki kabın ağırlığı basınç
kuvvetidir O da zaten içerideki sıvının
ağırlığı kadar g kadar bölü alan ters
çevirince bu G'nin değişmediğini
söylemiştim ama alan değişir Eskiden
şöyle geniş bir alana oturmuş
durumdaydık şimdi daha dar bir alan
oturuyoruz yani şuna oturuyoruz alan
küçüldü o zaman basınç büyüt Peki bu
katının zemine uyguladığı basınç kuvveti
o zaten ağırlık değil miydi burada geyse
zemine uygulanan basınç kuvveti f g
kadardır burada g ise zemine uygulanan
basınç kuvveti F yine g kadardır Çünkü
bu katıya dışarıdan müdahale yok bu sıvı
gibi değil bu sıvıya kenarlar müdahale
ediyor sıvıyı kaldırıyor Ama bu katıya
dışarıdan böyle bir kuvvet etki etmiyor
hocam yan yüzeyler var işte onlar zaten
katının bir parçası kendi kendine mi
yardım etsin Adam tek başına bir katı
çevirdim sadece ağırlık aynı ağırlık
katılarda ağırlık basınç kuvvetine
eşittir kabı ters çevirdiğinde kabın
zemine uyguladığı basınç artar ama
basınç kuvveti değişmez buradaki sıvı
için ve katı için tanımlanan basınç
kuvvetlerini iyi ayırt etmeniz lazım
farklı şeylerden bahsediyor Çünkü ikisi
de biraz kafa yormanız lazım Evet sıvı
basıncı bu kadar bütün konuyu soru
tipleriyle beraber halletmiş olduk Ama
zaten bir soru çözümümüz de olacak
ekstra takıldıklarınıza yazın Kendinize
iyi bakın görüşürüz
[Müzik]